is it acceptable to shout down a speaker
that compares black lives matter to the
KKK I I don't know I'm scared to say
that something wrong what about a
speaker that argued that trans women
shouldn't compete in women's sports yes
if it really was something so egregious
that it required to be shoted down then
they would if people don't want to don't
want to engage with it they don't have
to go to the speaker event so what about
a pro-life speaker yes no no no I don't
think so okay what about a speaker from
the ACLU yes no I struggle to say that
like it would be unacceptable to shout
down anyone and that if you are being
shout down shouted down here you
probably just aren't like a great person
as a citizen of the United States I feel
like I have the right to express my
excitement or disdain for a certain idea
showns are actually not first amendment
protected speech because it's using
speech to physically prevent someone
else from speaking so does that change
your mind at all a part of my heart
still wants to believe that it's all
right to engage in a shutdown